you know many years ago I read a book by
Terry Cole Whitaker it was a classic
what you think of me is none of my
business
think of the amount of time that is
wasted on negative energy wondering what
other people think of you what they
think of you really doesn't make any
difference it's what you think of you
that makes a difference so as you go
through the day don't worry about what
other people think of you just say I'm
all right
I'm God's highest form of creation on
the other side of the terror barrier is
something we call freedom and you know
very few people go through that terror
barrier it's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that could not live the way they want to
live
why don't they they don't know and they
don't even know they don't know fear
causes them to stay where they are on a
conscious level we experience doubt the
dope turns into an emotion called fear
and that fear is expressed through the
body as anxiety see that person is
getting emotionally involved to move
ahead do you know what happens they hit
that terror barrier and they bounce off
it and right back into bondage and
they're so relieved to get back there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've cancelled the sale they've
decided not to move they're going to
stay in the job that they don't like at
least they're comfortable now that's not
a very good way to live and you know
something that's something everybody
experiences if they're going to grow
you're gonna hit that terror barrier see
the terror barrier is going beyond where
you're at going to a new level I'm going
to tell you something when I set a goal
yep if if it doesn't scare and excite me
at the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction and if you don't learn
to go through the terror barrier I'm
going to tell you something you're gonna
stay right where you are for the rest of
your days that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say so true
the cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek
you just watch two amazing clips from
Bob Proctor take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]